is it right to say that 2020 is going
out with a bang in the world of anime
an unprecedented new contender for the
next big thing has risen in this final
stretch an attack on titan's final
season hasn't even aired yet will we get
a demon slayer this season
not likely but fret not to prove my
point let me introduce to you 10 of the
great non-sequels that this season has
to offer
because even if you take out your
sequels this season has turned out to be
more or less even stronger than the
previous one
so tell me what you like wholesome
romance high octane action
comedies that can and will most likely
turn into a fields trip at the end
remakes that aren't exactly remakes fall
2020's got it all for you
for our first entry we'll go with kimi
sin and no i'm not gonna say that whole
title out
anyway is it just me or is romeo and
juliet officially the japanese people's
favorite classic literature reference
it's got to be either that
or alice in wonderland right well kimi
sin which i'll just be calling our last
crusade is this season's romeo and
juliet retake despite it looking like
kirito just went looking for a new job
after alicization ended our last crusade
takes things in a different direction
that's quite familiar for fantasy light
novel anime fans yet a bit different
from what we've been accustomed to
first of all no it's not an izakaya for
once and no it's not a show starring an
author self insert who goes from weak
neat to the strongest harem king in the
universe
our last crusade talks about the good
old conflict between the worlds of
science
and magic as well as two of the
strongest fighters of each faction
falling in love with each other shared
by their common goal of wanting to end
the pointless war the factions have
gotten themselves into
having watched it i'd say that it's got
a lot of good moments and great
chemistry between not just our main
couple but also other allies within
their nations
probably not gonna be something people
remember this season for but for a
seasonal
i really enjoyed it
i talked about this show a lot in the
preseason introductions and as early as
then i already prepared myself for an
emotional roller coaster
but at the time of this writing we still
haven't got to the tears part of the jun
maida bingo yet
i mean well we got some headway into the
bingo yet with baseball among others
for me where the day i became a god
really shines is in the character
interactions i just find myself
thoroughly entertained and laughing with
how the characters act around each other
it also helps that our supposed god who
would bring about the end of the world
in the month acts like rister
aqua or all those butt monkey goddesses
who react in over-the-top
ways despite that the series doesn't
completely fall off the rails in terms
of the plot i'm not sure if i can call
the end of the series correctly or not
but i'm quite positive that the series
tone will soon flip and we'll be in for
a bittersweet finish of sorts
now before we resume with the show i'd
like to inform you that this video is
sponsored by
shining beyond developed by the
singaporean studio 12
braves shining beyond is an idol action
hybrid game that should save
all gamers needs for anime-esque action
on the go immerse yourself in its world
with its roguelike battle design
supported by music from the best of the
best
including hitoshi sakamoto music
producer of final fantasy 12. what makes
shining beyond so special
well check this out shiny beyond is one
of the friendliest gacha games ever with
a pull rate of five percent for ssrs
the rarest and most powerful units at
your disposal
and the ability to actually craft them
it's by far one of the easiest games to
get a maxed out party in
having your dream team full of your
dream waifus or the strongest possible
lineup has never been so easy before
when you're all set to go
it's time to start taking down enemies
you can choose to do battle on your own
but
if you're one of the social types shiny
beyond also has a real time co-op
feature
so you can have the chance to kick ass
with your friends what's more awesome
than slaying the monsters
with friends now how does that sound for
a mobile game let's help each other out
and support my channel by downloading
shining beyond
and just for you i'll be providing a
special download code for the game to
give you some exclusive rewards so hurry
up
and click the download button below so
that by the time you finish this video
shiny beyond will be ready for you to
launch on your mobile phones
wow they actually pulled it off and i
don't mean that in a good way
yeah i can understand your pain when you
enter the season all excited for one of
the best and most popular webtoons out
there
only to see an adaptation that continues
from the ova
yep i'm confused as well i never thought
they'd do it and now i'm sure glad to
have talked about the start of the
series in my preseason video because
you're not getting any of those
background plot lines in this adaptation
rest easy i may have sounded a bit harsh
with novelis but my main grievances just
late in how this adaptation is
structured as for everything else like
the art the sound the overall atmosphere
i think that it's a pretty decent series
being a fan of power fantasy and
overpowered characters i still find it a
joy to watch right and how he deals with
the world around him the supporting cast
is no slouch either i look forward to
the protagonist's eventual confrontation
with union the clash with the shady
organization will be a joy to see
and could make the whole journey worth
it
drive makes it to the list as our next
entry coming into the season i felt that
akudama drive had potential
it seemed to be the dark edgy hit of the
season and it gave me some vibes similar
to blood blockade battlefront tobokano
what i got is more than what i asked for
especially given the last few episodes
akudama drive starts off as your edgy
story about gangs and a divided country
you know the drill for these titles some
fight against the system themes going on
probably spray with some grim dark
pseudo philosophical things and all
but akudama drive completely blew me
away given my previous expectations i
fully expected it to be another 7 out of
10
show but it just keeps me watching with
how it successfully masters the art of
using tension and having a cast that's
more than the sum of its parts it's edgy
eye-catching and exciting those are some
words that i can use to describe akudama
drive the surprisingly good story is
just the icing on top of what i could
pan down as the underrated gem of the
season
who knew that a remake would look so
good over a decade down the line
actually that statement is only half
true for higurashi 2020 will it be a
remake
will it be a sequel those were all
questions asked when it was first
announced and we ended up getting
well a little bit of both so what they
did was remake the arcs but deviate from
the original roots endings and it's been
met with a mixed reception to say the
least
not to say that higurashi has lost its
magic but i think that in terms of being
a premier horror anime especially
something that can scar the uninitiated
use of the 2020s is still got it
it just looks different must be the eye
it must be the overall atmosphere being
too refined and bright for a horror work
still i think that this tale of a boy
settling into a cursed village with
girls who aren't who they seem at first
hand
still stood the test of time the story
itself is still as engaging after all of
these years will it live up to the
status of its predecessor
well it's too early to tell at the
moment but i'm keeping my hopes up for
this one
[Music]
i mean it's got a serious case for it
honestly speaking i think that it's one
of the shows that gets
all the right things done and avoids
pushing trigger buttons for a lot of
anime fans
rent a girlfriend i'm looking at you
that's not to say that the series is
playing it too
safe in fact its premise is quite unique
in a sense that you've got the
characters married from the get-go
thus moving past the romantic chase part
which the traditional rom-com spend
about 90 percent of their air time on
it's very wholesome and has a unique
thing going for it in its premise and
while there's not much of a plot to it
there's really no need to have
one you watch this anime mostly for the
comedic and lovey-dovey moments from our
main couple
it's got those in spades to keep you
entertained and charmed to keep watching
who needs the drama of a runaway sunday
girl simping escapades or some top class
high school bullying when you can just
drown in the wholesomeness of sukasa and
nasa's relationship
overall a recommended watch and if the
art looks familiar
it's because the guy behind this is the
same one behind hayate the combat butler
[Music]
our next focus anime is the movie burn
the witch
seeing taito's name in another anime
makes me happy
i credit blues to be one of my favorites
when i was starting out on one of the
most
influential shows on a personal level
and now i get to see kubo's work again
in the form of the anime movie burn the
witch
going from the feudal japanese aesthetic
that we've become used to we get taken
to the modern city of london
with dragons and witches in a movie
former are we sure we're not watching an
anime version of fantastic beasts with
buddy cop protagonists personally i
think the burn the witch needs some
serious reconsideration when it comes to
the pacing
when people said that they felt that
they're watching the fifth episode of a
one course show
they're not wrong the narrative has this
tendency to just skip all over the place
however it's not all doom and gloom
i personally found the movie very
entertaining in terms of the banter
between our main characters embargo i
found myself captivated in its
self-contained story and the character
arc of the focused characters and the
climactic battle had me getting all
hyped with bleach said to make its
glorious comeback
burn the witch is a good way to save
your cravings for the bleach universe
these comparisons aside i found burn the
wish to be a good miniseries
i feel that with a few more episodes to
help establish the world or set up a
bigger overarching plot
it's something that i'll gladly follow
on a weekly basis
coming up next is talentless nana
humanity is once again under attack by
monsters known as
enemies of humanity humanity's only hope
lies in the hands of the talented
humans with superpowers in order to
continue the fight to save humanity
schools have been created in order to
train these superhumans and hone their
abilities right i know what you're
thinking
isn't this my hero academia with aliens
or something
anyway our hero nanao is your standard
withdrawn protagonist having no
friend is no handicap for anime
characters especially if you can get
yourself
a huge pink girl as your special other
with her telepathic abilities
nana forms a bond with nanao and after
finally unleashing his talent in a
scuffle
nothing can stand in the way of na now
oops turns out nana's a talentless all
along no special powers
just assassin's skills and insane powers
of observation
and she's been sent as a mole to kill
the superhero wannabes by the way
however will every student be just as
easy to fall as nanao
i just find it ironic that the show came
out right around the time the among us
craze is still going strong
what seemed to be a superhero shonen
fair turns out to be quite the
interesting psychological thriller that
shouldn't be judged by its cover
pink kind of sus hmm
second place for today's list is
moriarty the patriot
when i said something about japan
borrowing from western literature i've
forgotten about the third contender
sherlock holmes japan just loves
sherlock holmes as much as alice in
wonderland and romeo and juliet it seems
however while we get a slew of shows
like gabukicho sherlock we rarely see
things from the perspective
of the villain moriarty the patriot is
here to fix that they say that the best
villains are those with the best
intentions
and you just can't help but feel
sympathetic to the most popular homes as
villains causes here
moriarty the patriot didn't get too much
hype in the preseason previews but i
think that it's one that struck the
hardest when it comes to reality
it's like looking at society with a
different set of lenses yes moriarty has
a flawed sense of justice but in a way
isn't it still a sense of justice in
real life i might not exactly like
people like moriarty but with the class
divide the way it's presented here
can we blame them this is overall just a
brilliant show
i didn't even talk about the
cinematography in the soundtrack which
by the way is amazing if you're gonna
pick a show to watch this season and
want to pick something that's so under
the radar in comparison to the big hits
and pick this one
as for why so many shows are under the
radar the answer is simple
and is the top show on this list jujitsu
kaizen
do you love it when you can predict the
most popular anime of a season a mile
away for the record when i was doing my
pre-season videos i successfully called
jiu-jitsu kaizen to be one of the most
hyped show for this season
the internet exploded with episode 7
thanks to gojo
jiu-jitsu kaizen seems to have the whole
anime community firmly in its grasp
one that it won't let go of anytime soon
an ironic word choice considering our
protagonist itadori has powers coming
from those deidara hands while i don't
think the jiu-jitsu kaizen has quite
reached the popularity that demon slayer
had last year
it's probably one of the closest we'll
get this year in terms of shonen
and how can it not be at a battle shonen
the series has it all
hype filled fights engaging characters
and a plethora of interesting powers
that get pit against each other it was a
promising series in manga form
and it should come as no surprise that
it ended up this way in anime form it
should also not be a surprise that it's
our number one new anime
on the list how about that then what's
your favorite new anime this season
what do you think needs more love and
why don't let those thoughts just be
thoughts and speak out in the comments
section while you're at it please hit
that thumbs up and ask your friends to
subscribe to the channel for more
content like this
don't forget to check out our sponsored
game shining beyond the links in the
description
with that we end this video and i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you